Ever since I was a little girl, music has always been like, a really big part of my life.
So, it's been really cool to, you know, be back into the studio...
...and working with people like Doctor Luke,...
...and amazing producers that I've been able to work with.
They're so refreshing to be around and their sounds are amazing,...
...and just really cool, and inspiring people to be with.
It's so much fun because you never know what you're gonna get when you go into the studio,...
...which is like an experiment, a scientific project.
And you go in, and you know, you get on a vibe with a certain person.
And then, right when you think you're gonna get bored, you know, the song's done.
And then, you go on with someone else and you know,...
...and then, add such a cool flavor to the CD.
It has like... it's like all different flavors of ice cream, you know. It's cool. ice creams.
I really have grown attached to these songs.
Just because if... like being in the studio and being able to dance to songs that I genuinely love...
...is like such... it's like rejuvenation for me.
And you know... and so, music is like such an exciting and a good part of my life.
It's really good for my soul.
So, you know, I love the music right now and I can't wait to go on the road with it...
...and share it with people.